[Music]
schools will be open and students will
be physically back in the classrooms on
monday but they're going to have to wear
a mask thank you for joining us i'm
christian casadas and i'm denise valdez
so over the next half hour we're going
to be giving you all the information you
need for back to school top to bottom so
let's start first with masks all
students and staff will be required to
wear them now there are 310 000 students
enrolled so far this year and 95 percent
of them have opted for in-class learning
there are a dozen schools offering
distance learning for people who are
taking that option and for those in
class mass and social distancing will be
back it applies to all students as
stated in the memo
as far as with the students with special
needs i know there are going to be some
exemptions made
the american academy of pediatrics has
said research consistently shows opening
schools in person doesn't necessarily
increase covet transmission when mask
and other protocols are followed the
school district says if a student does
have to stay home they'll make sure they
can still do classes from there
the number of students who need free or
reduced lunches and breakfast is the
highest it's ever been right now about
75 percent of students are receiving
them because of a waiver from the usda
all students are at ccsd can get a free
breakfast or lunch right now without
filling out any paperwork so what's on
the menu
a new
elementary entree salad and it's called
our rainbow crunch salad it has tomatoes
carrots lettuce
chicken cheese and then their choice of
dressing this is a teriyaki chicken
salad this is our vegan burger
french toast jenny o
biscuit
with turkey sausage that's available
all right well the ccsd dietitian says
they're always making sure that work
that basically all the fruits and
vegetables are in there now kitchen
staff are also wearing masks and doing
the hand washing that everyone else is
doing
lunch has come a long way i just used to
get a grilled cheese and chocolate milk
school bus is going to be back on the
roads too on monday the district has
between 1500 and 1700 buses running
students and drivers will both wear
masks when they're on the bus and
drivers will also wear face shield when
kids are getting off and on they will
load on one side and then unload on the
other so kids aren't crossing paths
executive director of transportation
jennifer bobis says there's an app that
parents can use to track where their
kids are
we encourage all our parents to download
the onboard bus which allows parents to
track the bus and where it's at and what
time pickup and drop-off is and they get
all the routing information there
now there is a bigger bus driver
shortage than normal so boba says other
people in the school district who have
another job but also a cdl license are
pitching in to help drive
there are plenty of cars to be wary of
two it's been a while since the school
zones were active in some areas so our
traffic anchor nate tannenbaum reminds
us of the school zone rules
well we all should know what the deal is
even if we might be a little out of
practice so whether it's 15 miles an
hour or 20 or maybe 25 miles an hour
when the lights are flashing that's your
speed limit lives are at stake and maybe
the money in your wallet also there are
some other frequently broken rules
around school campuses here's one you're
not supposed to flip u-turns around
school zones you're also not supposed to
pass other vehicles in school zones by
the way school zones are active when
there are three things going on either
when children are present when those
flashing lights are on and it also
includes 30 minutes either before or
after school
back to you
good reminder thank you nate well school
police also say there will be plenty of
first time teen drivers out on the road
so watch for that as well now during the
pandemic school police took the
opportunity to do crisis intervention
training that teaches them to deal with
students who are having mental health
issues now there are concerns there
could be an increase after the pandemic
school police spokesman brian zinke says
their presence will be known on campus
our plan is to have at least two
officers on every single high school
campus and then everyone else will be
supported by our patrol officers they'll
be out patrolling the elementaries and
the middle schools
while a lot of other departments in ccsd
are dealing with larger than normal
staff shortages zinc says ccsd police
are hiring but are only dealing with a
normal amount of officers leaving we'll
changing the grades up next in our back
to school special there will be a new
grading policy this year we break the
differences for you plus what won't be
included in student scores now and which
precautions will be taken on the field
the sports policies to prevent cobit we
are live local now